for the 27 year old heart throwing
red-handed from son christie ball in the
dominican republic
frankie montage two up and two down four
seven four era an outlier performance
his last time out against the arizona
diamondbacks allowing nine runs and an
ending in two thirds two home runs in a
game which the a's lost
by a 10-1 final so here's la stella
playing first base today
stella smokes this one toward piscotty
piscotti on the move and he reaches out
and makes a nice running catch
that's a two and two challenge here it
is trying to hit it he did it hit it
hard
stephen piscotti playing him correctly
with his mask on
there's anthony rindon he was batting at
314 with six armors and 16 rbis 5 for 10
on the series in his last 12 games
he's 23 for 47.
two balls two strikes two outs we're in
the first don't hits this one towards
the oh that's through
he is unreal extend the streak not a lot
of ways to move but just a little bit of
a stride and that is it and hands
through the baseball
gets it through the hole between short
and third start number six for dylan
three and two in the 2.48 era his last
start was against the san francisco
giants at home
on tuesday a day game when four innings
gave up four runs on four hits
walked four so matt's out 4-3 simeon
goes to third two-way and that'll bring
up chapman is batting 250.
no score bottom of the first chapman a
line shot toward goodwin left goodwin
going over not gonna get it sails over
his head
simeon's gonna score and matt chapman
gives the a's a one nothing lead with a
run scoring two uh double uh matt
chapman he let this ball come to him
and just his way of seeing in this
series this ball is up
it's a hanger he finally got to one
here's canna who's batting 283
chapman leads and the pitch is swung on
and looped into right center for a base
hit and the a sick of two nothing leech
happens around third to score
canna comes through once again with a
soft line drive
base hits a right center and it's two
nothing a's already
well how about the pizza hitting by mark
canna stays inside the ball
fights it off gotta fly ball to right in
the first inning
shallow center it's gonna be a long run
for everybody again loriano hustling in
and it falls but he's gonna throw to
second and did they get him yes
what a great play frankie montoz hustled
over to cover
second base and they got the force out
look at that throw
unbelievable this is a tremendous play
because it was only going to be laureato
kim gets out of the way
short hop in all the while chase what a
play
unbelievable the angels have runners at
second and third
one out two on pitch ohtani drills one
out to left center field that is
long gone and the angels are on top
three two
second career home run for shohei
ohtani versus frankie montas he's been
waiting hit a ball like that for a while
439 feet that's his swing that's his
power
did that part of the field 111 miles per
hour exit velocity
don't have second goodwin today a
strikeout
and a pop out good one rips the first
one into right field and piscotty is
going to cut it off it'll bring home a
run
heading to third as ohtani rbi single
for goodwin
expands the angels lead to 4-2 well it's
good to see that from good he's been
waiting for a while to square up a
baseball and a big smile on goody's face
coming through 13th rbi
goody going after the first pitch
fastball and it catches a lot of the
plate after walking shohei tries to get
ahead on brian goodwin
he's ready for it and now these have to
deal with mike trout is all for three
today
and two for 11 on the series and now the
delivery to trout as the runners lead
and murphy sets up outside in a breaky
ball on the outside corner trout knew it
he walked away before the call was even
made by jim reynolds
chapman rbi double in the first inning
lined out sharply to rendell in the
third
that one he did not go either see no he
did
joe madden can't believe it no they just
kicked somebody out joe madden
yep there was the first base umpire
lance barrett usually when umpire says
no more
the next peep whoever it is is gone
monday now at 97 pitches
before that double he had retired 11 out
of his last 12.
and that's a base head so piscotty's
going to come through with a two out rbi
hit to make it four to three
that is so huge murphy is up against
mike myers who's making a second
appearance
of this series the asf piscotty is
second they have tony kemp at first
pitch hit up the middle and it's going
to get through the center field
biscotti scores and the game is tied
one out one on four to four eighth
inning
hit hard up the middle siemens got it he
flips to second to get the out there
took a hit away from fletcher and thanks
to a great diving
sob catch by that man marcus simeon and
a flip to
kemp who's at second base so now the
runners are at the corners the hitter is
canna
this should do it trout's going to go
back he's going to circle underneath it
in deep right center field beretto
tags here comes barreto and the a's are
going to win it
so mark canna keeps it simple a
sacrifice fly
and the a's with their fourth washoff
win
of the year and they take the series
over the angels final score today
five to four